I am Loki of Asgard and I am burdened
with glorious purpose hey youtubers is
Charlie happy geek week so they just
debuted a big thor trailer but since
this is Tom Hiddleston's last movie but
it's not the end of Loki I thought I'd
do a video for future Loki projects that
are coming including some possible
agents of shield that's right Tom
Hiddleston just did this really awesome
interview where he talked about really
wanting to be on Joss Whedon's agents of
shield TV show and while I don't think
that he's going to appear on shield
during season one I do think that we'll
see a Loki movie during phase three and
here's why number one he stole the show
at Marvel's comic-con panel it was the
biggest event all weekend long and he
basically headlined the entire event
that's right the cast of the guardians
of the galaxy Captain America the Winter
Soldier they were all very
tongue-in-cheek and honestly their
panels weren't that informative it was
really Tom Hiddleston's performance that
stole the show Marvel fans will do
anything to get information on upcoming
Marvel projects but I think that they'll
do just about anything to get a Loki
movie honestly how good was Tom
Hiddleston during that panel all it took
was some pointing around and some
mewling quim and he just totally killed
it number two Tom Hiddleston still has
movies on his Marvel contract so when
actors signed with Marvel they typically
signed six picture deals and Tom
Hiddleston has only done a couple of
those meaning that he could show up in
future Marvel films if Marvel's decides
to use him what it basically says is is
that Marvel can use the character
anytime they want and Tom Hiddleston is
compelled to come act in the movie
obviously you would want to come act in
a Marvel movie just because it's so
awesome since they've already announced
all their movies for phase 2 obviously
he's not going to be in Avengers 2 so
that means that if he's going to be in
any future Marvel films it'll be in
phase 3 and Marvel has a history of
spinning off standalone films for its
biggest characters and who else is
bigger in the Marvel Universe from the
villains standpoint that Loki right now
yeah yeah yeah we know about fan o's and
all those are the big villains but
honestly they've just had brief cameos
Tom Hiddleston is a fully fledged
character and he is amazingly popular
right now that also goes to say that we
might see him in some non movie con
- for Marvel think about at Marvel
releases short films almost every year
so the recent one agent Carter actually
features Peggy Carter from the first
Captain America movie so it's always
possible that Marvel could use Tom
Hiddleston's Loki character and a
project that's not a feature film
obviously I don't expect to see him on
TV anytime soon I feel like that'd be
too big of a step down for him but we
might see him with some media tie-ins
number three Tom Hiddleston is
relatively cheap and amazing to work
with so obviously a lot of the actors in
the Marvel Universe have started to get
bigger and bigger as these movies have
gone on think about it Robert Downey jr.
was a big big problem for Marvel when
they were casting Avengers 2 and
Avengers 3 he was the last person to
sign on and it was all because he cost
too much money he was just too popular
Tom Hiddleston is also crazy popular
right now but he's a fraction of the
cost meaning it's much easier for Marvel
to produce a film and justify his salary
number 4 unless they completely resolve
the Loki conflict at the end of Thor the
dark world which I don't think they will
there'll be a big cliffhanger for Loki's
character just like at the end of the
first Thor movie you remember he got
sucked into that black hole obviously we
don't know how his character is going to
end in this second Thor movie but
honestly Marvel does a really good job
of seating teasers that just sets up
future films so honestly I think that's
what they're gonna do they're just gonna
leave him with a really open-ended
ending and number 5 finally my personal
favorite reason Loki is just too complex
of a character and Tom Hiddleston is
just too popular to ride the bench it's
basically like putting your a list
quarterback on the bench he's basically
the biggest villain Marvel has right now
and the one that people love to see the
most obviously Marvel doesn't want to
over expose them too much so there is
some logic in them not using him at
every single movie but obviously you
don't want to let too long a period of
time to go before you bring them back
out again or else people will start to
lose interest but let me know what you
think are we going to see a Loki movie
after Avengers 2 and what other projects
are we gonna see Tom Hiddleston's Loki
character in that being TV shows media
tie-ins commercials let me know what you
think honestly I don't think we're gonna
see him on any TV shows and personally I
think that there's probably a better
chance of maybe a Hulk movie happening
before a Loki movie is because Mark
Ruffalo's character is just
little bit bigger and Marvel's eyes but
let me know what you think like I said
earlier it's geek week and Marvel just
debuted a big trailer for Thor the dark
world obviously this trailer features a
little bit more about the story and a
little bit more of Tom Hiddleston's
character there was a scene during the
comic-con teaser they showed where it
almost looked like Loki chopped off
Thor's hand too so I really think that
that might lead to something interesting
in the story if it turns out to be true
if you haven't seen the comic book
version of Thor right now there's
actually a future version of Thor that
actually has prosthetic limbs taken from
the destroyer so there is the
possibility that Thor could be losing
one of his hands a la Jaime Lannister
Game of Thrones in this movie and
remember Alan Taylor is a game of
Thrones director he directed Thor so
there could be some crossover but let me
know what you think I'll be doing a full
review of the trailer later today so be
sure to subscribe to get that video I'm
also doing a preview for x-men Days of
Future Passed
Sherlock season 3 and a bunch of other
awesome geek week stuff I got a big
Legend of Korra contest coming up that
I'm gonna announce on Saturday and I'm
going to Disney's d23 Expo this weekend
so there's so much awesome stuff
happening please subscribe to get all my
videos I'll get them out as fast as
possible in the meantime you can click
here to check out my review that Thor
trailer and you can click here to check
out my preview for x-men Days of Future
past thanks so much for watching happy
geek week high fives
you